was war das er läuft einfach durch den
block durch
gerade für
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge hacker show und das
ist ein format in dem ich euch hacker
mache er das e mails schickt vorstelle
und zwar gestaffelt also 12 33 der
krasseste ist in einzelne einsteiger als
also der lustigste kommt immer am ende
so dann statt mama die erste einsendung
ist es nicht nicht die erste ist es
quasi so ein ami school ist es eine
kleine vorspeise die stadt vom clown
kräfte hatte ich eine richtige
einsendung aber schaut einfach mal rein
also ja es ist einfach selbst irgendein
video aufgenommen und dann einfach so
bevor auch schon nimmt so alles klar
dass da unten so ein kenner die durch
die gegend so viel zur 05 den
einsendungen dann kommen wir jetzt
zuerst
die ersten sendung leute und wenn man
genauer hinschaut sieht man hier dass da
schon spieler in dem ort ist an dem er
eigentlich nicht sein sollte die
einsendung stammt von orange meiner und
er hat geschrieben extremer flow hacker
welche meinte auch extremer flow also
solltet ihr in dem video ein flotter
entdecken dann gibt es im bescheid
wir schauen jetzt mal ein ja ist ja ok
na klar läuft erstmal einer durchs bild
runter roadbike was ist das ist es immer
so of the ways auch er hat sich jetzt
umgebaut und den spectator ok macht ist
sky wars oder hab ich gesagt etwas das
ist glaube ich eine art skyward sword
base kann es seien ja kommt sich alles
wie sie endlich mal jesus 6,4 dem wasser
unter aber jetzt mal wieder bleiben noch
in der luft stehen dinge also kommt
schon warum ich warum dürfen dann auch
eine ende werde also ich meine du kannst
durch die gegend fliegen warum wirst du
eine ende april zurück wenn du gerade
fünf blöcke rausgeflogen ist von der
mittleren base macht keinen sinn aber
ich hätte keine gegner wie man sehen ob
da noch klarer anna dann stets report
zeigt sagt harry potter ihn schon direkt
im video ist auch nicht schlecht
ich glaube hecking ist hecking trifft es
ganz gut oder das mal anschauen wie er
einfach da noch mal durch die luft
fliegt also komm schon vega bleibt
wenigstens nicht mitten in der lohnende
stehen mitten in der luft aber dass wir
schon zu ende geht
soweit die erste einsendung hier seht
ihr den namen des hackers also sich
mitten in der runde in die luft zu
stellen zeit schon preis dann noch einen
appell zu benutzen egal
ok weiter zur nächsten sendung
der nächste einsendung ja ok schau mal
rein
da geht's schon los
der erste steht dich so ja das ist aber
eine flanke das ist kein gag oder
begleit heck ist es war dies verstanden
ab so dass man sich hochbauten dann
runter segelt aber quasi abschüssig aber
der läuft einfach jetzt gerade durch die
luft okay des scheins bei her hat er nur
noch weg jetzt verkauft das geld aber
wird über blogs und dann ja ok hatte nun
marc beck wahrscheinlich schon
lisicki meter an genau das ist aber
jetzt gerade ein anderer das ist jetzt
der zweite hacker in dieser runde
sie schreibt im ernst in den chat kann
ich sehr gut verstehen da hinten gucken
wir laufen zwei leute durchs bild hier
sieht man es achtet man einmal auf den
hier den roten und auf den gelben sie
laufen einfach beide durchs bbf lag der
faktor zwei leute alles da
weil es jetzt noch ein dritter was mit
dem der hat irgendwie auch nicht so viel
noch bei kann das sein
kommt noch mehr piquet kühler auf jeden
fall auch da was ist auch per server des
auf jeden fall nicht komme nein ist es
nicht komme ok also hier haben wir
gleich mal drei gestalten auf einem
fleck und zwar hier einmal mehr frei
hacker einmal hier frei hacker respekt
in der luft da okay alles gut und dann
hier in der mitte diesen dritten der
auch hektar der der ist am anfang
geflogen glaube ich dass da aus dem
roten aber hier hat er es aber nur noch
bergtrikot noch bergmann wir gehen auch
mal zum anfang zurück ja da ist nämlich
der rote der pflicht auch durch die
gegend ja drei fucking fleischhacker in
einer runde
tja da hatte die die gute chemie 01
ziemlich pech und klarer auch um ihm
klar dass er gegen drei hacker einfach
auf das witzige ist sie fleißig sie hat
wirklich gegenseitig bekämpften wie man
einfach hier sieht
die box sie aber gegenseitig bisschen
was ich gar nicht mehr näher darauf ein
typ steht in der luft und schaut dem
anderen beim kämpfen zu denn hier sieht
man auch noch mal dass er auf jeden fall
nochmal kilo anhalt stück trotzdem also
muss man nicht mehr dazu sagen
die nächste 1 sendung stammt von jannik
krüge hacker auf das dem es heißt die
als gerade ein hacker und ich bin mal
gespannt was der macht den namen mit
wieder sehr penetrant aber okay bob was
war das durch die wand gelaufen hitze
gar wirklich durch die einfach durch die
wand durch durch den blog hier alles da
ich dachte schon ich hätte schon paar
hacks gesehen aber mit srk wieder
durchgegangen
das habe ich wirklich noch nie gesehen
einfach ein hack mit dem leute durch
wände gehen ich nehme mal an das ist
kein item ist dass es auf das dem ziel
geht mit dem durch wände gehen kann hat
er vielleicht noch andere die aufnahme
ist bisschen regine das schwarze balken
am rand was auch nicht so porno ist aber
okay heißt aktionen von ihm auf jeden
fall ja und jetzt ja da spielt im milieu
okay das war schon krass nach kiel aus
ok dann response blog abgebaut personal
bastian was macht er jetzt eigentlich
darunter fliegen müssen com hat die
kamera drauf er drauf hat auch wieder
durch die hatte ihn durch die wand
durchgeschlagen der standort da unten
drin oder hier
diese szene nochmal guck mal hier also
man sieht hier nie da ist niemand als
soldo war für die schwarzen balken aber
so hat er das leider ein geschickter
kann ich jetzt auch nichts machen wenn
ich das jetzt vergrößern würde würde er
von teil des bildes fehlen aber es
schaut mal hier
dahinter ist der gegner jahr und
irgendwie schafft dass ihnen dadurch zu
schlagen oder noch in mir aus
zurückkommen achtet mal drauf sagt er
schlägt er jetzt irgendwie rein und
irgendwie bekommt er ihn heraus jack
laura sowieso und sein major nebenbei
auch noch ein bisschen länger weg ganz
echt die krasseste szene war einfach
dass hier sag mir mal eure meinung was
war das er läuft einfach durch den block
durch mordtag eiskalt er steht davor
beim kanal springt wie hoch und läuft
dann einfach durch den blog ich mutter
fragt also ganz ehrlich ich hab mir mal
eine kommentare was ihr davon haltet
gibt es so ein durch die wand lauf heck
ich hab keine ahnung also ich meine ich
kenne jetzt ein paar hacks auf jeden
fall aber von dem hack mit dem man durch
die wand laufen kann habe ich auch noch
nie gehört oder war das ein bug wurde
was ist ihre erklärung schreibt auf
jeden fall notwendig
momentan rein das wasser weit von den
ersten dreieinhalb einsendungen zum
abschluss noch eine kleine extra eine
sendung für euch also quasi fünf
einsendungen der heutigen folge
vielleicht wird die bisschen länger
einfach zurücklehnen genießen ich komme
hier einfach mal so weit drüber
schaut einfach mal selbst wenn hektisch
sein sollte dass rückkehr sein kann man
schon mal sagen das war's so weit von
mir wenn euch das video gefallen hat
dann das gern in abu dhabi hacker show
gibt's jeden sonntag auf einem kanal
immer neue hacker best off score
ansonsten können aber sonst mal checken
was ich so mache würde mich freuen und
der hey bist dann zeige ich so macht es
gut und in jedem fall den ausländern so
schiller oder nicht hat sich wirklich
sagen vielleicht nicht wir müssen am
besten leute das was mir auch reinmacht
gut und ja